yeah yeah welcome back so the plan is
that I'll finish up the proof for the
lower bound on the extension complexity
of the correlation polytope and then
Hamza is gonna take over and talk about
the SDP extension complexity okay so
just a very brief reminder the
correlation polytope it's the convex
hull of these two to the n many vectors
that are just the outer products of some
zero one vectors with a with itself it's
going to be it's it's in a PR pollito
but kind of surprisingly we can show
that the extension complexity is large
and so we do know all the vertices of it
but we don't know all the inequalities
and but we can kind of get around that
by just taking a family of valid
inequalities and the families of valid
inequalities that go as follows for
every zero one vector a we can write
down you know like this inequality and
this is a valid one which we saw 30
minutes ago okay so good okay so what it
actually means is that we will not show
a lower bound on the non-negative rank
of the actual slack matrix we only shown
on a lower bound on the non-negative
rank of a sub matrix of the slack matrix
that still is going to be a lower bound
because like the non-negative rank
doesn't get smaller if you like remove a
couple of rows and but the matrix that
we're talking about it actually it has a
very nice crematoria definition you have
the following it's our for every zero
one vector a and we have a row and for
every zero one that could be we have a
column and the entry is precisely and
this is precisely the slag that we
actually calculated in the last on the
last slide so this is just one minus the
intersection of both both like sets or
zero one vector squared
okay so to live it like this is the
picture this is like the edge of
polytope and now we have in some high
dimensional weird space we have some
valid inequalities okay and in
particular there will be only two types
of entries that are sufficient for the
lower bound if a and B are disjoint then
if you if you plug this in here then
we'll see a 1 in the matrix and if a and
B share precisely one index then we will
see a 0 in the slack matrix and the
magic is that actually we don't care at
all about any other entries just this
property will be enough to show that
they're non-negative rank is 2 to the N
ok by the way there is a nice geometric
interpretation what it means if you have
only a subset of valid inequalities and
not all of them so this is just a side
remark one connect you show the
following if you have some points X and
they lie in there they all satisfy some
valid inequalities and you define it
like a partial select matrix of these
points with respect to these
inequalities so it's a little bit like
you have the convex hull of your points
and they are contained in in these
inequalities if you look at the parcels
slack matrix of like these points with
respect to these inequalities then you
can also wonder what is actually the
non-negative rank what is the meaning of
the non-negative rank of this matrix and
it has precisely the following meaning
it is the extension complexity of the
smallest polytope is it is the smallest
extension complexity of a polytope that
you can send which between X and P
okay so we don't actually need that but
it's it's a nice geometric inside and
this can be proven very similar to Jana
caucus theory oh okay
but anyway we have our sled parcels like
matrix and we want to show that it has a
high high non-negative rank and we will
actually use the erecting or covering
lower bound for that
okay so again there are these two
families of entries we have we have
toppled and B that are disjoined and for
those top holds we'll see a plus 1 in
the slag matrix and if you are do a
quick calculation like how many of these
entries do you have then this must be
three to the end
okay just double check that you're not
all sleeping why three to the end
ah well for every index for every index
I they're kind of like three choices if
you want this joint this joint topples
it's like none of like a 1 and bi ma I
and B is zero or one of them or one of
them as well so there are three options
and so you have three to the N many how
many choices okay oh good so the other
hand there are these these other entries
where a and B share precisely one symbol
and we calculated that actually then in
the slack matrix you will see like the
opposite you would see zero okay so if
you now apply the rectangle covering
lower bound and in particular you know
that there must be some number of
rectangles at most extension complexity
many rectangles and they are covering at
least you know the ones this one entries
here at they definitely that they cannot
contain any of the zero entries okay
okay so we have to show that you know
there are plenty of those rectangles
needed and the most obvious ways just
have a counting argument and so the most
obvious thing would be to show that
actually whatever rectangle you have
well it cannot it's it's not allowed to
contain any zero entry because then it
couldn't be part of her like a rectangle
covering and then just out like how many
of those you know one entry is here can
you have and in fact one can show that
this is at most two to the n okay now
how many rectangles do you need to cover
three to the N many entries if every of
your rectangles can cover at most two to
the n okay you can do the math so that's
exponentially much many okay now so this
is the only thing that that remains to
be proven that whatever rectangle you
that does not contain a pair a be
sharing one entry you can't cover at
most to to the end of these entries so
okay that's the statement okay ah
and we'll prove this by by induction
okay so how do you prove things by
induction well if you have n elements
you take a limit number one and you mess
around with it so we'll do the following
imagine this is our rectangle it has are
many many A's and many many B's and
let's sort them so that these are the
bees that don't contain the first symbol
these are the bees that do contain the
first symbol and these are the ones that
these are the ones these are the A's
that don't contain one and these are the
is that to continue what okay so you
want to improve things by induction so
we'll define another rectangle which is
like a smaller one it's a subset of our
rectangle where we take only the bees
that don't contain one okay similarly we
define a second rectangle where we take
all the all the pairs they'd be in our
rectangle where the one is not contained
in a okay so the bound you want to prove
by induction it's two to the N you split
your problem into two parts okay and now
you want to do the following so each of
these is a rectangle that does not
contain a pair a be sharing precisely
one symbol because
okay okay sorry no okay now we're doing
the following we delete the symbol one
okay we delete the symbol one from all
the tuples and then we want to apply in
Dutch because now we have one symbol
left okay so if you stare at let's say
the blue rectangle here then you only
took the bees that where one was not
contained in B so if you know what
happens if you contain if you delete the
symbol one well the one may have been in
the A's but the one was never part of an
intersection pattern so deleting it does
not change the intersections so still we
have two rectangles r1 and r2 that do
not contain a pair a be sharing
precisely one simple okay that's that's
good so we have our subproblem we could
split it into two parts
we imply that we apply induction and
everything is good and in particular we
also covered all the entries that are
disjoint because like this thing this
area here doesn't have disjoint are
pairs a B because you know like one
would be contained in a MDP okay there
is an issue here so you would like to
finish the proof here but that would be
a little bit too fast okay where's the
issue the issue is the following
imagine you have a you have a set a that
doesn't contain one and this is in the
rectangle and also this thing Union one
is in your rectangle and now if you
delete the symbol one then kind of you
have a topple that collapses to the same
and now you're counting it but you're
counting at only ones but you should
have counted it twice so you're counting
is messed up okay not good on the other
end
staring longer at this you know this
topple is counted in the blue
dangle this one it's actually it's it's
called so counted in the red one it's
counted in well it's contained in both
rectangles and then you're deleting
things and things collapse but you know
it appears twice and it is counted twice
because you have two rectangles so
that's good
two and two fine but there could be a
problem there could be a problem that
actually there is a pair a B no none of
them containing one they are in are also
the pair B and a Union one is in your
rectangle and also a and B Union one is
in your rectangle then these collapse
the top let's collapse your counting
them twice but they exist three times so
then you haven't counted them enough but
this is not happening so why is that
this not happening because well then you
would have this thing in your rectangle
you would have this thing in your
rectangle and they would intersect
precisely in in in that symbol one and
this would be forbidden pair but you
don't have forbidden pairs so we're good
okay this is a it's a it's a beautiful
proof by kaibaland Petka it was not the
one that was originally used but this is
a it's one that I actually like quite a
bit okay questions
so this is this was actually the
complete prove that the correlation
polytope has an extension complexity of
at least one point 5 to the N and ok so
that's the end of this part and now
Hamza is going to take over and he's
gonna explain how a CP extension
complexity work there are no questions
for Thomas and start okay so so yes I'll
talk about semi definite programming
lifts ok so so I guess the mission and
Pablo already talked a lot about semi
definite programming and so on so I will
not have to do a lot of introductions so
so essentially what is a semi definite
programming so this is the picture that
Pablo drew one on the board so I see my
definite program is essentially the
problem of optimizing a linear function
over a set that has the following
geometric picture so it's the
intersection of the positive
semi-definite cause what is the cone of
d by D symmetric positive semi definite
matrices with an affine subspace that I
call L here ok and so I'm going to say
that a convex set C has a semi definite
programming extended formulation or semi
definite programming left if it can be
written as the projection so PI here is
a linear map of such a set ok of the
intersection of an affine subspace with
the cone of positive semi definite
matrices so the reason we're interested
in such a representation is because if
you have such if you have such a
representation of your convex set C then
essentially optimizing a linear function
over C becomes a semi definite program
ok of size D by D ok and so the the the
SDP extension complexity of a convex set
C is the smallest size of an SDP lift
where I measure the size of GSDP lift as
the size of the cone so the the D here
ok this is somehow of a proxy to the to
the complexity of solving the SDP
of size so note for exaggeration of
linear programming lifts
if if your subspace L here is is
included in the subspace of diagonal
matrices then what you get upstairs is a
polytope okay and so what you
essentially get is an NP lift of so here
it has to be a polyhedron okay so so
this is so the LP extension complexity
that thomas talk talked about is always
greater than or equal than the sdp
extension complexity so is the
definition clear okay so so let's let's
look at a very simple example of an SDP
lift of a convex set okay so here I'm
going to take my convex set is going to
be the square so that's minus 1 1 square
that's what is represented here and I'm
expressing here my square as a linear
projection of a certain of a certain
spectral hydrant so that's the an
intersection of an affine subspace with
the cone off of positive semi definite
matrices so this spectral hitter is
described by this by this thing okay so
you look at 3 by 3 positive semi
definite matrices with a diagonal equal
to 1 ok so that's a three dimensional
convex set and the claim is that if I
project this convex set on this
components x and y what I get is the
square okay so that's a an SDP lift of
the square of size 3 so so why is this
equality true okay why is this true is
because let me just give you maybe One
Direction is if this matrix is positive
semi definite then you see that all the
2x2 minors have to be non-negative okay
so this this determinant has to be
non-negative so one minus x squared has
to be non-negative the same one minus y
squared have to be has to be
non-negative and so X has to be between
minus one and O and the other direction
I'm proving that this is including this
is also is also not not difficult so so
this is one example so you see that the
convex set here in this case was a
polytope but of course you can do things
other than polytope so the other example
that this was actually in Pablo's talk
if you look at the nuclear norm ball so
that's the set of matrices of size n by
M whose the sum of singular values is
less than one that's called the nuclear
normal that shows up in in many
applications
has a semi-definite representation okay
which which again is the one that Pablo
mentioned okay so here's the additional
variables are X and y okay and the size
of the representation is essentially M
plus n okay because this is the size of
my matrix here of my PSD okay and
another example so I haven't written it
written it up explicitly but that that
was mentioned in initial initial stock
is that the the stability number the
stability the stable set polytope of a
perfect graph has a semi definite exam
in extended formulation that was shown
by lavash okay and this the size of this
formulation is n plus 1 where n is the
number of vertices okay so these are
just some examples so so so so so
there's one kind of key difference
between LP extend informations and SD
picks and formulation is that you can
actually do convex sets okay so so in in
the LP world if you take a polytope and
you projected you get another poly tope
okay but here you can potentially get
convex sets that are not polytopes okay
and so we saw the we saw the nuclear
normal okay so of course yes
so a trivet for any convex set you mean
on no so so so so I'll come to this
right now machine okay so not not all
convex sets have a semi definite
presentation but that's actually a very
recent result okay it's not yeah
so so so yes so so so the question that
you can ask is what are the set of what
are the convex sets that actually admit
in the first bit as a semi definite
affirmative okay so there's one
necessary condition that you can that
you can write okay so that so of course
he has to be convex okay this is clear
because the linear map of the linear
image of a convex set is convex but you
can also see that it has to be say my
algebra okay so remember what is a
similar bike set a similar bike set is I
said that can be defined using
polynomial equations and inequalities
okay so an example of a non similar bike
set is the the epigraph say of the
exponential function okay you cannot
write it using polynomial equations and
inequalities you can approximate it as
closely as you want but you cannot write
it exactly okay the reason as
semi-definite representable set has to
be similar break is is the following is
because I mean the the cone of positive
semi-definite matrices is defined using
polynomial inequalities okay that's the
the miners have to be non-negative
and then you intersect it you get you
get a similar break set and then there
is the result of tashkent Seidenberg
that tells you that when you project a
similar bike set it has to be similar
break okay so that's that's the first
necessary condition that you can write
there has to be convex and same
algebraic okay and then the result of
course the the question that is it true
that any convex similar break set has to
is easy modest representable okay so
this question has kind of some history
in optimization you continuous
optimization so let me just mention
mention briefly so so so anyone in
continuous optimization knows about this
book okay so this book is by Bentall and
nemirovsky
okay so two famous continuous optimizers
so this book is essentially a
compilation of a lot of convex sets and
they're semi definite representations
okay so it gives you it for example
it tells you how to give them a
different presentations of the LP norm
ball for NEP bigger than one that is
rational for the shuttin LP knowns the
Newton or ball sums of K largest
eigenvalues geometric mean of eigenvalue
I mean many convex functions that shows
up in practice they give semi definite
presentations for them and in fact all
these are implemented in software that
people in continuous optimization news
okay so like this is really the
underlying results that that underlie
really CVX and jung if you know what
this software okay so these are tools
that allow you to easily solve
optimization problems so so so this is
the the yes this is the book by Ventura
and Amir OPSEC and then so nemirovsky
was was invited as a plenary speaker at
the ICM in 2006 and then he posed this
question is it true that any so that any
convex same algebraic set has a semi
definite list okay and he said that this
question seems completely open okay if
you read his his his kind of his survey
so so then there were some results by
Bill Hilton and jungjie in 2009 in 2010
the truth is essentially that if the
boundary of the convex set C is smooth
and has positive curvature then it has
an SDP okay so they showed a series of
results that essentially the results
have the following flavor that is the if
the boundary of the convex set see that
the similar break is smooth and has
positive curvature then it has an SDP
d'If so let me just kind of pause a bit
on and talk a bit about this assumption
so this assumption looks I mean looks
innocuous but actually it's it's quite a
strong assumption okay so many of the
convex sets that we deal with in
practice are actually non smooth I mean
their boundaries are non smooth if you
just think about the about the positive
semi-definite cone the boundary of the
positive semi-definite cone is a non sum
is non smooth okay so it is the
essentially the boundary of the positive
semi-definite cone can be stratified
according to rank okay
each stratum is is smooth but the
boundary as a whole is not smooth okay
so so and in fact if you just think
about polyhedra and so on these are all
have boundaries
non-smooth so this is quite a strong
assumption so nevertheless I mean they
actually conjectured at the end of the
paper that that this is true that any
convex image bikes that has a similar
representation and then so so okay
algebraic geometers then jumped into the
this problem
so in particular Klaus right there who
is in at the University of Constance
he showed actually that the conjecture
that that the proposed is true in in the
plane okay so they showed that that any
convex same algebraic set in the
Plainsman dimension to has a similar
programming lift in fact he actually
showed more generally he showed that in
any dimension the convex hull of any one
dimensional same algebraic set had the
semi definite programming leaf so so
okay so so I mean if you take a convex
image break set in the plane its
boundary is the one dimensional same
algebraic set okay and so so this is why
it implies in particular conjecture in
the plane so so there's one case where
you can actually prove this relatively
easily if you look at the convex hull of
what we call rational curves okay so
these are curves that have a rational
parameterization and this was actual
result of Pablo that he showed is that
these do have an SDP representation okay
so so close essentially generalize this
to any to any engine to the convex hull
of any algebraic and then very recently
this is just last year the clouds showed
that that there are actually many convex
same algebraic says that do not have an
a DP representation
[Laughter]
so so let me let me actually let me
mention so he showed that there are many
of these and I mean his contractions
actually really explicit so he shows
that the cone of non negative
polynomials whenever these are different
than sums of squares do not have an SDP
representation so so remember that so I
can define the following cones so p.m.
2d okay so this is the set of
polynomials in n variables of degree
less than 2d okay such that P of X is
non-negative for any X in RN okay so
this is a convex cone so remember the
picture that that Pablo did on Monday I
guess is so you can look at the at the
following table so you look at the
number of variables okay so 1 2 3 etc
and then the degree and you can ask when
is it true that any non-negative
polynomial in n variables of degree at
most two D is a sum of squares okay and
so he showed that this is the case in in
this situation and this was the the kind
of the this was the some of the
exceptional case that Hilbert showed and
and then these are the all the situation
where this is not true so so in all
these cases we know that this cone has
the same address representation because
we know that sum of squares
Pournami that are sum of squares can be
represented using SDPs so what hey what
clubs actually showed is that in all
these other cases there is no hope of
finding any same enough representation
okay so no matter how clever you are and
so on you cannot find one
yes so this is all I wanted to say about
this
the proof is relatively technical and so
on it is a very heavy algebraic geometry
maybe Cynthia you can yeah yes so so
yeah so this was kind of about the story
of the this is the which convex sets are
admit a semi definite presentation so
from now on I'm going to actually talk
about so I mean this I call this the
existential question okay this is more
of a mathematical question now what I'm
going to talk about it I mean in the in
the rest of the talk is more the
complexity question okay where we're
essentially you take a convex set that
you know has a semi definite
presentation which is typically a
polytope and you ask what is the
smallest possible semi definite
representation of of this I mean I have
until what time okay so I have a half an
own so okay so let's let's work with
polytopes
okay so I have a polytope p so so to my
talked about slack matrices and how
slack matrices allow us to understand
the LP lifts of polytopes I'm going to
do is exactly the same and I'm just
going to introduce a new notion of
factorizations of matrices and I'm going
to show that this is related to SDP
factor SDP liftoff of the pollito okay
so remember that the the slack matrix of
a polytope is defined as follows so it's
a matrix where the number of rows is the
number of facets of the polytope and the
number of columns is the number of
vertices of the polytope and and the IJ
entry is essentially the slack off of
the of the J's vertex with respect to
the ice facet okay so this is bi minus
AI transpose VA okay so that's a non
negative matrix so let's let's just to
give a very concrete example so if I
look at the the square again and and
this part has four facets and four
vertices how do i construct the slack
matrix so I look at the
first facet and I evaluated that the
four vertices so say I ordered the
vertices in this way so this this this
and this so I'm just going to copy this
number 0 1 1 0 and then I look at the
other facet I get 0 0 1 1 etc so these
are the cyclic permutations of these ok
so this is the slack matrix of the
square so now I'm going to introduce a
new notion of factorization of
non-negative matrices that's called the
positive semi-definite factorization so
so if I take m a matrix with
non-negative entries I can try to
factorize my matrix as follows I want to
find PSD matrices AI and BJ of size D by
D such that the IJ entry of my matrix is
equal to the trace of AI and DJ or the
inner product of a IMG does the trace in
a point okay so the trace inner product
of two positive semi definite matrices
is always non-negative ok so that's why
M has to be non-negative
okay so the smallest D is called the PSG
rank of my matrix so so you can see that
actually the PhD rank is always smaller
than the non-negative rent so why is
this the case yeah so just take diagonal
matrices a and B J okay but it can
actually be substantially smaller so let
me give you a simple example let's look
at this this this matrix M so it's not a
slack matrix just kind of to play around
a bit with this notion of PhD
factorization this is the matrix I minus
J square okay this the item J entries I
minus J square so this is how the matrix
looks like so you can show that the PhD
rank of this matrix is equal to two
independently of M ok of the size of the
matrix so how do you do this so this is
just a factorization given as follows so
I'm going to associate to the I throw
the following matrix so one III squared
that's actually a Rank 1 PSD matrix and
I'm going to associate to the jth column
BJ which is just again this Rank 1
matrix and you can verify very easily
that m IJ is equal to the trace of a I
and BJ sorry that should be a non here
if you just do the the inner product of
these two that's just the inner product
of this vector with this vector squared
so that's just minus J plus I the whole
square
on the other hand you can it's not
difficult to show that the non- rank of
this matrix is a grows with n and it
grows that's log n okay you can show
it's easy lower bound that this grows
with Logan in fact it's actually I think
equal to small also then to log N or so
so so yeah there can be a big gap
somehow between the PhD rank and the
non- fine
so the theorem now is is the theorem I
think that you would expect is that if I
take a polytope e with a slack matrix M
then the SDP extension complexity so
remember this is the smallest SDP left
of P is equal to the positive semi
definite rank of of the matrix M of its
slack matrix okay so this is a the
analog of the theorem that that tamo
mention okay and in fact the proof is
really very similar okay it's it just
uses the duality or Farkas lemma for SDP
so maybe I can actually go over the
proof just
so again there are two directions in the
proof right so I take P this is the
convex hull of a certain set X okay so
my slack matrix is indexed by the facets
and and the and and the vertices X of
the polytope okay so I assume I'm going
to assume first that M has an SDP
factorization
of size D so this means that I know that
mij which is essentially bi minus AI
transpose XJ is UI comma VJ okay and I
want to show that my poly tope T has an
SDP lift of size D so I'm going to is
exactly the same thing that that term I
did so I'm going to write so I know that
P can also be written in the following
form so this is B minus a X non-negative
so on and then I'm just going to say
that this is the set of X in RN such
that B so I'm going to write it this way
is equal to UI a comma V
or V is positive semi-definite air
exists
I'm essentially going to write this I'm
going to introduce this additional
variable V okay and I claim that this
equality is true so clearly if I taken
an X that is here then I know that B
minus a X is non-negative because the
inner product of U I and V is
non-negative because U is PSD and V is
PSD so this gives us one inclusion okay
and the other inclusion uses the fact
that X is the set of vertices of of my
pollito okay so what do I have to show I
have to show that anything in here is in
here okay so if I take a point in here I
know it's a convex combination of
elements of X okay and so I can I know
that for each element of X there is a
certain V J and if I just take V to be
the convex combination of these things
I'm going to get this this equality okay
it's an easy and easy it's again exactly
similar to to what to mention and then
you can also show the the other
direction so so the other direction this
is what where you see the Farkas lemma
showing up
what do we want to show so we want to
show that assume I'm going to assume
that P has an SDP lift okay so in
particular I'm going to write this as DP
lift in a certain form and this is
without loss of generality so such that
so I'm going to assume that the
projection is actually just forgets a
certain number of components okay so so
I have to show that that my slack matrix
has a positive semi-definite
factorization so how do I do this so so
I look at a certain facets so that's a
certain row of my matrix so B minus a
transpose X this is non-negative for any
X in P but then I can actually also
think of this as a valid inequality on
my convex set upstairs okay so I know
that this is true also so I'm going to
lift such I'm going to think of this as
a as a valid inequality as upstairs so
this is V minus a transpose X is
non-negative for any X Y okay in my
spectra hi John s okay so this is my
spectra hiddenness is essentially the
set of XY that satisfy this let me let
me write this is set of XY
and then but then now what does Farkas
lemma tells me Farkas lemma tells me
that since I have here a valid
inequality that is true on this then
that this inequality has to be
essentially something that you can
obtain by by taking non-negative
combinations of this okay but in the SDP
world what this means is that you
essentially hit this with another PSD
matrix okay so so let me let me make
this a bit more clear so if you look at
the set of XY that satisfy this PSD
constraint then you can think of what
are all decided what are the valid
inequality that you can generate from
this okay and so the valid inequality is
one way to generate such inequalities is
to just pick any PSD matrix call it D
say and hit it and hit this matrix with
it okay so we look at B comma this and
this will always be something that is
non-negative on the spectrum and what
Farkas lemma tells you is that this is
everything that you can get okay that
any valid inequality and this has to be
of this form so so so then this implies
this is for customer
that'd be minus a transpose X has to be
of the form say u comma F 0 plus X 1 F 1
etc plus y 1j 1 and this is true for any
X 1 okay so this is an equality of
linear forms we find a final form so any
X Y in RN + RM ok and then now we're
actually almost done because now what I
only have to do is to get my
factorization so remember I want so I
have my you this will be the thing that
indexes my my row which my row is
indexed by a facet and then now I pick a
vertex and I know that the vertex
actually has to have a certain Y above
it that lives in the spectra he'd run ok
and I'm just going to take my my PSD
factorizing to be this matrix for the
corresponding one okay so for any X in X
I know that there exist a certain Y of X
such that X Y of X lives in s okay and I
can just bring so I'm just going to take
G of X to be this this whole thing okay
so let me just write F 0 plus just going
to write this so it's where f of X here
is just this linear form and gngo of Y
is this linear form okay so this is PSD
and what I get is essentially that B
minus a transpose X is U comma V of X
so we're we're so are you and V effects
are PST ok so and this is this is my
factorization of I don't know if it's
visible but so this is my factorization
of the slack matrix u here depends only
on the facet which is corresponds to B
na and V only depends on an X my vertex
ok so the proof is really simple if you
didn't kind of follow maybe all the
details it's just really an application
of Farkas lemma you take a linear linear
inequality we left it upstairs and so
yes so so so maybe what I want to
explain is actually the connection with
sums of squares okay so so Pablo and
uncle talked a lot about sums of squares
and so on and I want to explain what is
the connection between lists of
polytopes and and sum of squares
hierarchies and and and some source
certificates and so on and so forth okay
so so what I'm going to start from this
so so I know that so so
what we've essentially showed is that if
you have an SDP lift of a polytope II
than what you have is essentially a
certificate of non negativity of your
all your facets of the following form
okay so so you have B minus a transpose
X is equal to u comma V of X for any X
in X okay so X are the vertices of my
poly tope but and U and V are PSD so so
if I die compose U and V so in their PSD
I can write them in the following form
so U is just the sum of UI UI transpose
okay and V of X I can write as the sum
also V of VI of X and V of X transpose
then what I actually get is that D minus
a transpose X is the sum of UI transpose
V J of x squared I'm just going to
expand this and so what have I actually
just done is that I've written my facet
inequality again as the sum of squares
of certain functions okay so I'm going
to write this as just a child of x
squared
okay well my age self as what they are
is that their linear combination of
certain functions VJ okay defined on X
okay so so here my H alphas belong to a
certain subspace V and my subspace V is
just the span
of the functions so Vijay - Vijay is a
vector so these are vjk from 1 to G okay
from 1 to G so so again what is inside
here is the sum this is an inner product
and Vijay is a vector so so what we've
written is that we've we've expressed
the dis facet of of the polytope as the
sum of squares of function from a
certain subspace V and the dimension of
this subspace
is smaller than this quite okay and
remember this square was the size of the
lift that we started so so let me just
then summarize the theorem so so so what
we've just shown essentially here is
that if I have an SDP lift of size D
okay so X here the vertices of my of my
polytope then there is a subspace V of
our 2 DX 2 R 2 DX here represents the
set of functions on X such that the
following holds that the dimension of V
is smaller than d squared and such that
any facet of P or actually any valid
inequality on P has a sum of squares
certificate where the functions H alpha
here are from the subspace V
and in fact this is this is an if and
only if okay it's it's also not
difficult to show that if if you have if
such a subspace V exists such that any
facet of P has a small representation
from from V then the polytope has an SDP
liftoffs as the dimension of it okay so
so there is a a gap here this is d
square this is d but it's not too
important I mean it's you can bridge it
if instead of looking at scale or sums
of squares we look at vector sums of
squares but let's I mean for it's not
the the main point okay and so are there
any questions about this is this kind of
clear with this I mean I just want to
make the point that constructing an SDP
lift of a polytope okay is equivalent to
to certifying the facet inequality of
this polytope using sums of squares from
a certain subspace and the dimension of
this subspace is what governs the size
of dsdp okay so if you're familiar with
the last set of hierarchy or the sum of
squares hierarchy for for constructing
polity for for constructing for
describing convex hulls of points then
the last Authority actually corresponds
to the choice of V being the subspace of
polynomials of degree at most K okay so
if you if you think of you can think of
polynomials of degree at most 1 2 3 4
etc of on X okay and you can try to
certify the facet inequalities of T as
sums of squares of degree 1 2 3 or 4 etc
ok so this is exactly what the last
hierarchy does is that it tries to do
this it tries to certify this and the
lesser rank somehow of the polytope is
the smallest K such that you can certify
all the facet inequalities using
polynomials of degree at most K
are there any questions about this is
this I'm going to give some examples now
okay so so so let's look at an example
just to make things a bit more concrete
let's go back to our square okay and
let's look at what this actually what
this picture what what does it tell us
so so the square is just the set X here
in this case is just minus 1 1 squared
is a set with four points and I have
four facet inequalities so 1 minus X 1
and negative 1 plus X 1 are negative and
so on ok I know what I'm going to try to
do is to try to write these facets as
sums of squares from a certain subspace
okay so what you can easily show if you
try to look at this function 1 minus x1
you can actually find this sum of
squares or this square just certificate
so you can show that 1 minus X 1 is 1/2
of 1 minus X 1 squared on the hypercube
ok it's very simple you just develop
this so you write you expand sorry so
you get 1 minus 2 X 1 plus X 1 squared
and you get you get your thing so this
is a sum of square certificate of the
non-negativity of this on here ok so now
now we have to look at what is the
subspace of functions under like under
the square okay that we used in in this
sum of square certificate so this is
just the polynomials of degree at most 1
so so here V is the span of constant
functions x1 and x2 this is a subspace
of dimension 3 and this gives us a lift
of size 3 of the square
okay and this lift is actually nothing
but the lift that I showed at the very
beginning okay with the ones on the
diagonal so here I only showed one one
facet but you can also it's very easy to
see that all these do have sum of
squares certificates from this subspace
V okay so really the key idea is it's
it's it's simple so you have a certain
convex set or a certain poly tope there
are certain non-negative functions that
you associate with these are just the
valid inequalities and finding small
certificates for these valid
inequalities allows you to get a small
lift off of this point so so so now I
want to show a more slightly more
complicated example so to kind of look
at the difference between the subspace
so so here this is the subspace of of
polynomials of linear polynomials of
degree at least one and I want to try to
see if you can try to look at subspaces
that are different than the than the
ones that are used in the last cell
hierarchy
okay so this is the the example of
regular polygons so this is maybe
slightly more complete than the square
but not that much complicated so so I'm
going to take the example where X are
the N roots of unity okay so this is the
you have the unit circle you look at the
n-words of unity here the seven and
equal seven and I want to try to
construct an SDP lift of this pollito
okay in the plane so again what I have
to do is I have to look at the facets of
this poly tope and I have to try to
certify them using sums of squares okay
so the first you if you write the
equations of this facet okay so this is
what you get this cosine PI over N etc
okay and it's not very difficult to show
that if you want to certify this that
this thing is non-negative for any X Y
or root and end through root root of
unity then you need to use polynomials
of degree at most at least n over four
okay you need to go to quite high degree
to be able to write a sum of a
certificate of this
it's not very difficult to show me
essentially the reason is because if you
use a smaller degree the the identity
that you would write would be valid on
the holes and the whole circle I mean
you would not feel the fact that you are
on on the end roots of unity and so it
would hold on the whole circle which is
not true so so so so what this means
again is that remember how how the how
the last aheri key work is that you try
polynomials of increasing degrees that
and until you can you can certify the
non-negativity of this and so what this
tells us is that you have to go to
degree at least n over 4 ok so here in
this case it would be n over 4 so this
would actually give you a lift that is
quite big so it would give you a lift
that is of size roughly and also so n
over 2 because in this case this is a
very special case where actually the
polynomials so each each subspace here
pull one pole 2 etc the homogeneous
polynomials of degree 1 2 etc each one
of these have dimension exactly - okay
these are the harmonic polynomials and
these are essentially the cosine and
sine so this is the cosine 2 theta sine
2 theta cosine 3 theta 3 theta sine 3
theta and so on so the question is can
you actually find a subspace to certify
this thing and the subspace has much
smaller dimension than than than linear
in n okay and it turns out that you can
actually can okay that you you can find
such a subspace okay and and the idea is
actually to just to pick and choose some
of this polynomial so to look at sparse
polynomials okay so to do something like
this okay and to take the subspace to be
just to skip many of these monomials
that you would not need and so how do
you do this so we have to find a certain
sum of squares certificate of L that is
that has this positive pattern and in
fact such you can okay here is it so you
can you can show that this is true so I
will not show it but essentially this is
a sum of squares certificate of n okay
and the key point here is that you see
what is under the square is also this is
the constant this is a monomial of
degree two to the J
and this is another monomial of degree
two to the J okay so essentially what
this means is that the only thing that
you need are the monomials of degree a
power of two you do not need really all
the monomials in between 1 and n over 4
you just need the ones that are a power
of 2 and so how many such monomials are
there I mean there are log n such
monomials okay so if you go from 1 to n
and so what this actually tells you is
that you can find a subspace of much
smaller dimension than the one that
let's say that in the that is
considering that in the last
construction and this surface has
dimension log n so it gives you a lift
of this poly tope an SDP lift of this
poly tope of size log n ok so I just
wanted to kind of again I mentioned this
example
so maybe the regular polygon is not a
very interesting I mean polytope per se
but just to illustrate this this idea of
choosing the off of this choice of
subspace is that if you want to rule out
essentially I mean so a lot of work has
been done into proving lower bounds on
the last a hierarchy so what you want to
show that you cannot certify such
non-negativity of something using
polynomials of degree less than
something to prove lower bounds and on
sdp lifts you need to show that you
cannot do so with where the subspace has
a dimension smaller than something ok so
it's a much I mean it's it's a much more
complicated endeavor somehow so are
there any questions about these examples
yes it know it's it's it's tight I mean
it's the same thing yeah yeah yeah it is
tight yes it is I mean I mentioned so so
here yes so so we showed that if you
have an SDP lift of size D then there
exists such a subspace of dimension at
most D squared but you can also show
conversely that if such a subspace
exists then there is an SDP lift of such
a dimension of V so so it is tight yeah
it is exactly
any other question yes you can actually
do log in with polygons on phone yes sir
but it's it's a it's a completely
different construction so so this one is
this one is really an SDP construction
and the other one is is due to actually
been turn anymore of schools so yeah
okay yes
let's actually see what we have yes so
maybe can I finish with this and then I
have I think two minutes or so I'll
finish with this so I wanted to kind of
finish all this picture with with with
this table so I was going to write it on
the board but yeah that's fine
so so so essentially the the connection
between hierarchies and extended
formulations okay in the LP and SDP case
somehow to summarize a bit the story so
we saw that I mean constructing an
extended formulation amount to certify
non-negativity of the facets of a
polytope okay so we saw that for SDP
extended formulations the way you do
this is that you try to write your
facets as sums of squares from a
well-chosen subspace and we saw that for
the Lasser hierarchy this subspace
essentially corresponds to the
polynomials of degree at most k so what
I mean how does this picture what is the
analog of it in the LP case so in the LP
case essentially what the picture that
term I explained can be also kind of
transcribing as follows is that you want
to essentially write your facet
inequalities as non-negative combination
of certain well-chosen AIS okay so these
areas are actually nothing but the such
either the column nor the rows of one of
the matrices matrices in the in the in
the SDP in the LP factorization okay and
and the other column essentially gives
you the non-negative weights that you
need to express all the all the all the
facets okay so if you think of all the
facets I mean the each row is
essentially a facet evaluated at X a
non-negative factorization tells you
that each row is a non-negative
combination of the rows of the of the V
I mean of the second Matrix in
interesting and so if you interpret
these the rows of the second Matrix as
the AIS okay this is essentially the
picture okay so it tells you and these
are the certificates of non negativity
of your head okay and so what do the
hierarchies again the hierarchies are a
special case of this when the a is our
very special functions that you chose on
X okay if you think of say the Handelman
hierarchy of the
maybe most commonly known as shredder
cheryl-lea Adams hierarchy which is in
the particular case when X is is a
subset of the hypercube defined using
certain polynomials it's very easy to
construct non-negative polynomials on
this set I mean you can for example take
any power of X so here I mean X 1 to the
alpha 1 and so on and any power of 1
minus X and then you can also take
products of these G is this gives you
certain non-negative functions and then
you can try to certify your facets as
non-negative combinations of these ok so
so so again there's a Handelman are
silly items hierarchy are our special
case of extended formulations when these
AR take take this form and then again
you can you form a hierarchy by putting
a bound on this alpha beta and gamma and
so on ok so I hope kind of this gives
you a unifying picture of I mean how I
mean how things just interact together
and and yes I think I'll close with this
thank you
you more questions not we'll take a
break
[Applause]